So I want to spend just a little bit of time
fact checking one particular re tweet that
has been the source of a lot of controversy
from Donald Trump's completely unhinged tweet
storm the other day.
And I want to really think about this in the
context of the chaos PR paradigm that we've
been discussing, the idea that maybe Donald
Trump benefits from unrest, sort of.
Either way, no matter which side the unrest
is coming from or whether Donald Trump actually
solves it.
The idea that Trump may benefit from it either
way, Donald Trump, one of Donald Trump's re
tweets during during his recent tweet storm,
is arguably his most blatant act of racial
incitement that we've seen.
And this was a tweet storm that was triggered
right after a right winger was shot and killed
in Portland.
Although Donald Trump was remaining very quiet
on Kyle Rittenhouse, the Kenosha, Wisconsin
shooter.
And within the tweet storm, Donald Trump retweeted
a video that was originally posted by a user
named I'm with Griper, which is a right wing
group.
They've since changed their name on Twitter
to try to seem as though they are associated
with an TIFA.
In any case, that doesn't really matter.
The video shows a scuffle on a subway platform
in New York City completely out of context,
which ends when an unidentified black man
pushes a bystander who is a white women woman
into a subway car.
It's completely out of context and in fact,
it happened in twenty nineteen.
It has literally nothing to do with what's
going on right now and the unrest that Trump
is trying to use to defend or perpetuate his
presidency.
The re tweet has since been deleted, but as
you can see, we still have it.
Originally from user name TTN and Noticias,
which is news or headlines in Spanish and
author and former speechwriter for George
W. Bush, David Frum commented on this, calling
it, quote, the most blatant act of racial
Insight's siteman in the history of that office.
Not even Andrew Johnson went this far, and
it is indeed a completely out of context video.
This video of a scuffle in 2019 on a subway
platform has nothing to do with Black Lives
Matter.
It has nothing to do with the protests that
are going on.
It has nothing to do with George Floyd or
Kenosha or Portland or anything.
And in fact, if you researched the story,
you will find out that this individual was
charged for shoving this woman on the subway.
And there is, of course, in the widespread
reporting about the incident, no mention whatsoever
about an affiliation with a social movement
on the right or on the left.
But this is a perfect example of how any random
video, any random incident, any random event,
even a picture is repurposed by white nationalists
and the president then ends up boosting it.
Now, did Trump fall for it?
Was Trump tricked here or did he knowingly
retreat something that he knew was from 2019?
It actually doesn't matter because the goal
is just to be a dog whistle.
The goal is to amplify these messages that
Donald Trump believes are beneficial to him.
It's very telling that regularly his instinct
is like put aside the facts.
This has not this video, this shoving incident
had nothing to do with BLM.
It wasn't even this year.
It wasn't even in the cities Trump is talking
about.
But Trump recognized it as a message or image
that was beneficial to him.
And it just so happens to be something that
was put out there by white nationalists.
And it's because Trump, Donald Trump has decided
stoking racial tensions is good for me.
Stoking unrest is good for me.
Creating racial division is good for me.
He may be right and he may be wrong.
The calculation would be it activates more
of his people than Biden's people to see this
type of stuff amplified by the president.
Anybody who opposes black lives matter.
In my experience, will use anything any black
person has ever done to try to make their
point, even if it has nothing whatsoever to
do with Black Lives Matter.
And that's what we're seeing here now.
I've gotten a few emails from people recently
saying, you know, David, you used to be critical
of Black Lives Matter and now you seem to
have fallen in line.
Have you been bullied by the left?
No, you are 100 percent correct that as an
organization, I have been critical of Black
Lives Matter in the past and I maintain every
single one of those criticisms, the anti-Semitic
edge.
The disagreement on tactics.
The belief that much of what has been done,
some of what has been done is counterproductive
to the cause.
But I am not going to fall into the criticisms
that are wildly racist from the right about
Black Lives Matter.
And more importantly, the primary message
of Black Lives Matter is one that I agree
with.
It's a disagreement on tactics and and on
certain elements of it.
But, Mike, the difference is my criticisms
of BLM are based on things that have actually
happened, not random videos from 2019 that
have absolutely nothing to do whatsoever with
Black Lives Matter or anything that's being
discussed
right now.